what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to blind dates before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in and as you already know if you have
watched two or more of my videos and you
don't subscribe we have beef okay beef
people he's having the ribs okay because
we're gonna share no no all right but
this is a big problem because I like to
pick up of other people's plates she's
gonna have the ribs and then can I have
a steak please
oh wow she's already trying to order for
him my girl like men don't like that but
like let me just give you a tip like
woman to woman guys like to feel like
they're in charge and they're in control
and they like to you know they like to
be the leaders like they they don't want
like a girl that's ordering for him and
telling him what to do I agree that
that medium rare that's the compromise
you tell him how he wants it there we go
what sauce would you like peppercorn
mayonnaise oh oh no she's gone gravy so
red wine chips
[Music]
okay
cheers
so you're stubborn then yeah I get my
get my own weight every time every time
every time
I need someone that's going to treat me
like a princess like giving you
compliments and stuff and just making
you feel good you know it's bad you
ain't chasing them that there are so
many men that will treat you like a
princess look at her look at her she I'm
sorry you might you could argue how hot
she is in the comments I don't really
care she's hot enough to get a guy that
treats her like a princess but she
doesn't want that guy no girl actually
likes guys that put them on pedestals
I'm sorry I don't care what any of y'all
female simps say when you're like oh no
we like the nice guy stop it you don't
want a guy you could walk all over and
it's extremely unattractive when you
walk all over a guy so I've had people
in the pasta didn't make me feel very
good
oh see I could have predicted that she's
like some some guy in the past didn't
make you feel good so what are you gonna
do you're gonna make the next guy pay
for the mistakes of your past so now he
has to deal with all this trauma because
you have bad taste in men
[Music]
like uh just pass X's like with their
like horrible little comments about I
don't know about the way her lips and
stuff oh it's why is it making me upset
I hope your stumps don't feel bad for
her for one second I don't feel bad for
one second you guys feel bad you feel
bad no because you picked him so you say
oh I want to be treated like a princess
no you don't and your dating history
shows that
I've been in one serious relationship
okay five years
why did that end he wasn't being very he
wasn't very nice some guys prefer you to
be like at home making a sandwich for
them
they like a girl that just says yes to
everything they do
I was definitely that gal and I didn't
have very good self-esteem I guess and
it just brings your confidence down a
lot
so that's why I like
I just yeah I want someone that says yes
to me to like no is never the answer
you just want someone to say yes to you
all the time what are you a child
sometimes
I love shopping just spend a lot of
money on her outfits
[Music]
good King don't let her disrespect don't
let her disrespect you that is so
disrespectful
foreign
[Music]
yeah maybe you need someone potentially
you don't always get your own way though
[Music]
I swear to God if I was the waiter I
would swoop in I'd be like look I see
this ain't going well here's my number
like
I said my girl what are you doing
I just want to go oh you want to go
alone I swear to God Alone
[Music]
cam
and I'm going back
I'm not okay
[Music]
um so she's left okay yeah
um
I just wanted to check in the all right
and everything yeah yeah it says swoop
in swoop in he ordered the steak in the
rib she's like he can afford a nice meal
swoop in she okay good good oh I need to
finish the drink if you want dessert you
can have a dessert
foreign
[Music]
the sad music oh my God like I like how
they paint her out to be the victim and
all that like they're letting her give
her some what about his side that's so
guilty but I just couldn't stay any
longer
did you mean you couldn't step
okay I'm sorry what do you mean you
couldn't stay in life sometimes you have
to stay at your job longer than you want
to because it's well you're supposed to
you know what she saved him his time no
I didn't fancy him
[Music]
fellas now I understand why people are
moving to other countries to find wives
because this is what y'all have to put
up with that's like a a six
a ten stop it stop it I can't even
believe my eyes anyways like the video
guys
um I'm sorry on behalf of modern women I
would like to apologize
oh that was so rude I can't even believe
she got on her phone on a date did your
mother not raise you right oh my God all
right like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible